hello more on those stories in a moment
but we are just hearing of a loud
explosion that's been heard near the
airport in kabul the cause of the blast
still unclear at this stage these are
the latest
pictures from their thick plumes uh
black smoke were seen in the kabul
skyline and that just comes
days after a suicide bomb attack killed
175 people including 13 u.s service
members well charles stratford is
live for us in kabul so charles what
more are we hearing
well what we know so far is very little
we began hearing reports of an explosion
in that area about 15 or 20 minutes ago
it was reported initially as being a
rocket attack or
or a rocket landing on a house outside
the perimeter fence of the airport
we can in no way confirm this but
certainly there seems to have been some
sort of explosion in an area beyond the
fence north of the airport now this area
is being some of the most congested of
all the areas all the gates
around the airport in recent days
it is obviously a worrying sign when
we've had these
alerts made
throughout the day initially reported
or threats reported by the u.s president
saying that he expected that it was
likely there could be an attack within
the next 24 to 36 hours that was last
night the situation is very tense around
the airport we know that security has
been stepped up by the taliban that are
supposed to be securing that area around
the perimeter fence but yes pictures of
plumes of smoke from some sort of
explosion
beyond the primitive fence to the north
of the airport
all right for the moment uh charles
stratford live for us there in kabul
all right uh actually we do have a bit
more time to to talk more about this uh
charles my apologies um
where do things stand right now as far
as the the the situation around the
airport with the with the timeline for
evacuations
um uh you know the u.s announcing that
it would be on on on tuesday uh and how
that is is uh is progressing at the
moment
well we know that the fights are
becoming less and less there's been very
few very little sort of air activity uh
that we've noticed we're not hearing the
planes that we've heard uh throughout
you know recent days we know that there
haven't been as many taking off or
indeed landing with very much in the
final stages of this massive evacuation
program that has now lasted uh two weeks
however we understand and we've seen
that people are still trying to
get onto flights um we understand now
that the only people being allowed on
have to be on sanctioned buses and names
their names have to have been forwarded
to the authorities beyond the taliban
control line but uh having spoken to a
bus load of people this morning who did
had those kind of that kind of necessary
paperwork they made an attempt to get in
and didn't
so um there it seems as if there are
going to be a lot of people as expected
who may have the necessary official
documents but will not be getting on
flights
um and meanwhile as we say the the
situation here is just incredibly tense
around the airport we had those
us a u.s drone strike that took out what
were described as two high-profile
members of
isil k the group that claimed
responsibility for those attacks that
killed more than 100 people a few days
ago interestingly the taliban condemned
those attacks as saying that there
needed to be more coordinates said that
they weren't consulted by the us
um before those attack that that that
strike took place
we know that the us and the taliban have
been
cooperating quite extensively certainly
in in recent days around the airport but
as this tension increases the closer we
get to this deadline for this evacuation
operation to end and with this threat of
a
of an attack hanging over
the thousands of people around the
airport and indeed all over kabul um you
know you can you can imagine that that
level of cooperation one would think in
these final hours is is is critical
and very much ongoing
yeah just picking up picking up on that
uh charles what what implications does
this now have on the the sort of gradual
handover of security from the u.s forces
to the taliban at this point
well the taliban and isil are our arch
enemies here and of course in
recent years
the the us has been helping the former
government here in dealing with the isil
threat the taliban have also actually
been complimented some analysts say
they've done quite well in preventing
other attacks by isil in afghanistan but
over the last three years or so they've
been responsible for some of the most
brutal attacks in this country hospitals
attacked
we've had a school schools attacked
indeed one maternity ward was actually
attacked by these
by this group so it's going to be very
interesting to see what level of
cooperation continues
between the us and the taliban in facing
the isil threat after the evacuation is
over of course it is in both parties
interests that uh that isil are stopped
because not only do they um pose a huge
threat to afghanistan but a a
considerable threat to
countries in the wider region indeed
around the world
as i said the taliban actually condemned
the the strike against those isil high
priority figures as they were described
in the last 48 hours or so but the fact
remains that it seems as if the taliban
are going to need all the help they can
get when they don't have the kind of air
power that uh that america can can
supply to uh to take out these isil
targets
all right for the moment uh charles
stratford life was there in kabul thanks
charles